lisa last word to you uh if you had a
moment
a salient moment to sit with joe biden
and offer some advice what would that
advice be to the president of the united
states i mean i'm telling he sucks uh
and he should resign and he's ruined the
country i mean really and honestly i
have no respect for this man he left
americans behind in afghanistan he's
intentionally driving up gas prices he's
doing as much intentional harm to this
country as he possibly could so i would
have nothing but unkind words to say for
him if i'm just being perfectly honest
with you so he wouldn't want to hear it
i'm not getting an invite anytime soon
jason
how you doing people i'm dave rubin this
is the reuben report it is july 11th we
are live streaming on rumble youtube and
blaze tv subscribe if you have
not and uh that was lisa booth fox news
correspondent lisa booth good buddy of
mine lisa booth proud floridian lisa
booth and the very same lisa booth who
will be joining me on stage this
thursday at the miami improv there are a
couple tickets left also christina pusha
who is ron desantis's press secretary
will be there and uh my buddy dave roboy
uh multiple reuben report guest daver
boy daverubin.com events if you want to
join us in miami and i just had to play
that clip regardless of lisa coming on
the show or not i mean
just like a perfect destruction of bite
and just like the whimsical way that she
says it says it like it's just like
nobody has respect for the guy and he
doesn't really deserve much respect
anyway i hope you had a great weekend uh
we are in the middle of the summer i do
have to say these florida summers not
too bad i had a nice weekend a little
bit of sweat out there walking the dog
saw some lizards it's all good some
parrots got a lot of parrots in my tree
in the backyard i hope you guys had a
good weekend as well uh and today
what we're going to talk about is
something that was sort of breaking just
as we were doing our live stream on
friday but then it fully broke
later in the afternoon i know i spent a
lot of time on the show talking about
twitter and elon musk and all that and
there's a certain percentage of you and
you're a wise percentage who are not on
twitter and i don't recommend if you're
not on twitter getting on twitter uh as
you know i'm trying to figure out how to
plot my exit off twitter i think these
things have to implode but you sort of
have to fight sometimes
where the fight actually is but i do
think that the twitter
situation and elon musk's purchase and
then non-purchase and now lawsuit over
the purchase or non-purchase
does represent something much bigger in
society related to free speech and
censorship and fighting the machine and
our political polarization and the whole
thing so in case you are living under a
rock and you did not hear uh late thurs
late friday afternoon uh elon musk
quashed the twitter deal
and the reason that he says he did it is
that while they were doing their due
diligence twitter either would not allow
him to see the actual data related to
how many bots there were or he got some
information related to how many bots
there are meaning fake accounts and if
there are all these fake accounts and
bots then it's like what are you
actually buying right like this bill of
goods doesn't match the actual product
and when you're spending say 44 billion
on something
uh you know basically you want to know
that it is legit uh you guys know that
i've been saying for a couple weeks now
as this thing
got a little weird and got delayed it
was like maybe they were going to find
out that the whole thing is fraudulent
i've sort of been feeling that for a
long time we all know about the shadow
bands and the manipulation and all of
those things and again for those of you
that are not on twitter that are like
why do you focus so much on twitter
whether you like it or not it is the
place right now it is the global pr
service where the where the taste makers
the influencers are and what starts
there leaks out into the rest of society
that may not be good i'm pretty sure it
ain't good but it is real uh so uh i was
calling it out uh there's a certain
orange man who said a while back that
this was not a good deal and it probably
was not gonna work out we got some video
of that
and this all sort of leads us to the to
the loser of the of the week and he's
going to continue his losing this week
uh joe biden just disastrous all across
the board and now the democrats more and
more are saying they want him out so who
will replace him and what will happen i
have some thoughts on all of that
anyways buckle in uh we got a big show
for you on this monday
first quick guys let me talk to you
about moic box you know 60
of us pork production comes from one
company and it's owned by the chinese
surprise surprise their hogs are given
something called rack dopamine which is
banned in 160 countries including china
yet you find it in your grocery aisle
every day there's a better way i want to
tell you guys about moiq that's moo plus
oink oink delivers grass-fed and
grass-finished beef and lamb pastured
pork and chicken and sustainable wild
caught alaskan salmon straight to your
door moik farmers farm like our
grandparents did and as a result moink
meat tastes like it should because the
family farm does it better the moic
difference is the difference you can
taste and you can feel good knowing
you're helping family farms stay
financially independent as well you
choose the meat delivered in every box
like rib eyes to chicken breasts to pork
chops to salmon fillets and much more
plus you can cancel any time i'm smoking
some serious ribeyes pretty much every
weekend at this point shark tank host
kevin o'leary called moiq's bacon the
best bacon he's ever tasted and ring
doorbell founder jamie simenov jumped at
the chance to invest in moic plus
they'll guarantee you'll say oink oink
i'm just so happy i got moint keep
american farming going by signing up at
mointbox.com reuben right now and you'll
get a free filet mignon in every order
for a year that's one year of the best
filet mignon you'll ever taste that's m
o i n k box dot com slash reuben that's
pointbox.com reuben i know back to me
all right so elon killed the twitter
deal although twitter is now saying
they're going to sue him to make the
deal happen this is the same deal that
the board tried to stop elon from doing
in the first place the whole thing is
very bizarre we've got some info here
from the daily wire billionaire
entrepreneur elon musk moved to
terminate his 44 billion dollar deal to
buy twitter on friday prompting a
virtual avalanche of commentary from
both sides on the social media platform
musk who has asked from the beginning
for data regarding how many fake slash
bot accounts there are across the social
media site sent a letter through his
attorneys alleging that the information
had not been provided and demanding that
the agreement be terminated
holy [ __ ] the party is really over here
dave rubin responded the purge is coming
think about the bot manipulation
corruption he found out about while
doing due diligence probably can't say
anything because of non-disclosures this
explains twitter's more brazen
suspensions and the increased shadow
banning lately what a [ __ ] that's
dave rubin for you this was the last
chance that something decent could be
salvaged from the nightmare that big
tech could become
the time to build new things was a long
time ago reuben continued okay so uh yes
i'm quoting dave rubin on dave rubin's
show but i think dave rubin got to the
heart of it uh there's a big problem
here the thing that is the mass
communication service that we have
in in the world right now really in
america but really it is the world
um is highly manipulated whether that's
through shadow bannings or d boosting or
fake accounts and all of those things
and that so it's like okay if you're not
on there you're going well why is any of
this important to me i'm just not on
there and i'm living my life and again
god bless you for it you're probably
doing it right however
when information travels there when
clips travel there when they hide hunter
biden's laptop and ban certain accounts
and say donald trump the president
united stands can't be on here but this
person can be on here or you can
threaten violence like call to arms like
mayor of chicago lori lightfoot but you
know if you're on the right you can't do
this
all of that then leaks out into real
world stuff so we've got a tweet here
from elon musk
uh oh well this is
a meme that he tweeted out they said i
couldn't buy twitter then they wouldn't
disclose the bot info now they want to
force me to buy twitter in court now
they have to disclose bot info in court
so this is one of those things where
people you know basically are like is he
playing 3d chess or 4d chess or 5d chess
8d chess nobody knows how many d's are
in the chest at this point uh you know
that basically he said hey guys just
give me the honest info of what's going
on here i'm willing to buy this thing i
want to defend free speech and remember
when he made the offer to buy this thing
and said hey i just want to open this
thing up defend free speech you know you
can't threaten to kill people but we can
have honest political discourse here and
sometimes you're going to be offended
and you can block people etc remember
everybody started calling him a racist
the new york times was writing stories
about him growing up in south africa
because of apartheid and he and his
family must be racist that's what they
do well anyway when all this was
happening it made me think there was
one guy who kind of predicted that this
was not going to end well uh i tweeted
this out about that guy the biggest
winner today is probably trump who
immediately said he wouldn't get back on
twitter even if elon bought it so you
may remember that remember that when
this all happened
in many ways you know a month ago when
elon was buying this thing in many ways
all roads were going to lead to trump
because there's all sorts of people they
can unban right you could bring alex
jones back on you could bring back a
series of of meme makers and all of the
types of people that have disappeared
but really what it would come down to is
trump because elon was not going to be
able to buy it and then say oh no but
donald trump can't come back on and if
he said okay trump's back on it's like
is the apple store now going to kick
twitter the twitter app out of the store
i mean that's why the internet and
solving all of these problems is so
layered and all of those things
anyway uh
trump then gave a talk uh over the
weekend and he addressed just that i
call that one right
leon's i tell you what
elon
elon
is not going to buy twitter
where did you hear that before
from me
from a fake account she says fake a lot
of them
nah he's got himself a mess
all right i'm only throwing that in
there just to sort of further solidify
this thing where trump basically calls
things and gets them right like he has a
really good track record of getting
these things right so whether elon gets
twitter now
whether elon's move was to destroy
twitter from the inside because now in
court they're gonna have to open up the
books and and show all of that stuff who
knows but right now there's a there's
sort of a win for trump there's a maybe
win for elon and twitter seems to have
lost no matter what and again i'm
rooting for twitter to lose i'll tell
you totally candidly at this point even
though i've spent a tremendous amount of
time and effort on twitter and i've
built i've you know over a million
people have followed me on there and i
get a lot of traction despite the way
they shadow banned me obviously they're
screwing with my account in crazy ways
right now and i got banned last week as
you know and all those things i i do
think that the best solution here
actually would not be for elon musk to
get twitter i think it's so rotten to
the core the host is so infected
that i actually think that the best
resolution of this would be that twitter
implodes it probably should implode and
we should all figure out other ways to
communicate with each other there are
things such as locals you can join other
video sites instead of youtube like
rumble etcetera etcetera so that's uh
that's my feelings on that but it all
goes to this sort of winter loser
situation because that is what's
happening right now we're in this shift
where some people they have a kind of
track record of getting things right
some people have a track record of
getting things wrong so who's kind of
the biggest loser in america right now
well all eyes are looking at joseph r
biden the elderly man pretending to be
president he is getting banged up within
his own party mainstream media online
media et cetera et cetera we'll get to
that in just a sec let's just talk about
policy genius for a moment you know why
get life insurance in an unpredictable
economy life insurance can offer peace
of mind that anyone who relies on you
financially a child a parent or even a
business partner will have a financial
cushion if something happens to you i
can attest i got two baby boys on the
way policy genius is an insurance
company uh insurance comparison website
that makes it easy to compare quotes
from top companies like aig and
prudential in one place to find your
lowest price you could save fifty
percent or more on life insurance by
comparing quotes with policy genius just
click the link in the description or
head over to policygenius.com
reuben to get personalized quotes in
minutes and find the right policy for
your needs the license agents at policy
genius work for you not the insurance
companies they're on hand through the
entire process to help you understand
your options so you can make decisions
with confidence and with thousands of
five-star reviews across google and
trust pilot policy genius has options
that offer coverage in as little as a
week and avoid unnecessary medical exams
head over to policygenius.com reuben to
get your free life insurance quotes and
see how much you could save and now back
to me all right
so biden he's a struggling i don't know
if they're letting him know that he's
struggling but he's a struggling uh even
cnn now is reporting that a lot of
people know something ain't right as
members of his own party and key
supporters are getting more frustrated
they're questioning if the white house
can muster the urgency to deal with huge
challenges from the economy to the
supreme court overturning roe v wade and
the rattled confidence is widespread a
monmouth poll just found 88 percent of
americans think the u.s is on the wrong
track that's an all-time low
okay that is a crazy
crazy number i try not to get lost
in stats and polls and things like that
because they can be manipulated i
generally don't trust cnn and often the
polling
organizations that they're using the
fact that cnn is putting that statistic
up 88
think that this country is on the wrong
track that's pretty much everybody
that's pretty much everybody that
includes some of the 81 million people
who voted for joe biden
everyone is starting to realize not only
are the policies bad across the board
the policies are bad bringing in the
woke stuff disaster
uh getting out of afghanistan whatever
in the high hell is going on with
ukraine inflation gas prices printed
money covered nonsense all the stuff not
only that but then of course everyone's
also seeing
that he's crumbling that the guy does
not have the mental wherewithal to do
this job everyone knows it and it's like
this slow motion truth sort of is a slow
motion or it's a time release to the
mainstream media we all see it we all
know it right but by the time the
mainstream media really gets to it it's
like that they've just had it ingested
in their system and it takes a little
while for the truth to actually get
through to them but it's not just cnn
that is uh finally admitting that things
are obviously not going well and that it
has something to do with joe biden check
out this tweet from the new york times
which is pure leftist trash as president
biden insists he plans to run for a
second term his age has increasingly
become an uncomfortable issue for him
and his party polls show many americans
consider him too old and some democratic
strategists do not think he should run
again now what's interesting is the way
they're framing that first as i said i'm
somewhat impressed that the new york
times is actually touching anything that
has to do with reality that's pretty
good and we should give them credit for
that the issue here is not straight up
joe biden's age you can be into your 80s
and really really sharp it's probably
not an age you want to be to be
president of the united states you
probably generally want someone
maybe in their four i would say 40s 50s
60s probably ideal in terms of full
physical health mental acumen and the
whole thing but that is not to say you
can't be much older and seriously
mentally sharp
watch my interview with thomas soul from
two or three years ago as i think he was
89 years old uh you can be pretty old
and pretty sharp at the same time the
problem is that joe biden is not sharp
the problem is that joe biden has shown
considerable decline in
let's say the last four years but really
really significant decline in the year
and a half it's only been a year and a
half that this clown has been president
so it's been bad here's a headline from
the new york times we showed you a tweet
a moment ago here's a headline from the
new york times most democrats don't want
biden in 2024 new poll shows with the
country gripped by a pervasive sense of
pessimism the president is hemorrhaging
support now this is why i keep telling
you guys they're done with biden biden
may not realize it but they are done
with him they don't let him hold his
phone he obviously doesn't tweet himself
they are often telling him to get off
stage when he gets on stage they tell
him exactly what to say we'll have more
on that in just a sec the machine
used old joe biden to push through this
progressive nonsense but they're almost
done with him
and my hope is that the lies the lies of
pretending that they were for him that
pretending that he's okay my hope is it
will take everybody out around him that
would be the way we get out of this uh
not just that they take him down and
then they gain more power right that the
progressives find someone even more
crazy radical and they run with it my
hope is that as we all see as joe biden
is exposed as nothing he's not a man
anymore he's just a shell of a human
that all the people who defend him who
are all in on it because they all know
something's not right that it'll take
them all down
here's kamala we showed you this one
last week i think it's worth looking at
again kamal is saying uh that you know
she'll she'll support him there is
speculation among some democrats and
some republicans that president biden
won't run for reelection in 2024 what's
your message to those who say that
listen
to president biden he intends
to run
and
if he does i intend to run with him
so there you go all right the cackle now
this time you remember the video that i
showed you last week where she was
saying he's going to run again and she's
going like this this time she's taking
notes so she's nodding yes he's going to
run again she knows he's not going to
run again she knows she's not running
with him she may run again not against
him she may run in instead of him but
she she knows it's a lie and she knows
something is wrong with him they all
know it they all know it uh remember aoc
at least she's being somewhat honest
she's saying she's not sure what she's
going to do oh i just want to ask about
president biden he is saying he's going
to run again in 2024 will you support
him
you know if the president chooses uh to
run again in 2024 i mean first of all
i'm focused on winning this majority
right now uh and preserving a majority
this year in 2022 so we'll cross that
bridge when we get to it but um but i
think if if the president has a vision
and that's something certainly we're all
willing to entertain and examine when
the when the time comes
that's not a yes
yeah you know i think we should
endorse when we get to it but i i
believe that the president has been
doing a very good job so far and um you
know should he run again i think that i
you know i think it's it's
we'll take a look at it
i cannot believe it despite the fact i
find her to be the most
vapid shell inauthentic
unpleasant dishonest
really vile human being who is here to
only destroy america i will give aoc
credit she's saying something a little
bit kinda close to the truth she's
basically saying hey we used yayol
bastard and she's not fully saying we're
not gonna support you because she knows
she has to play the game of politics but
the way she's laughing and we'll get to
the decision all that she knows she
doesn't want to buy it and she wants a
true radical socialist communist someone
probably even worse than her and we'll
get to who that person might be in a few
minutes um but i'll give her credit for
saying something kind of honest as
opposed to kamala who's pretending that
joe biden is going to run again and
speaking of pretending that joe biden is
going to run again here's kp
do you expect president biden to run for
re-election in 24
and if not will you run
yes i do expect him to run i'll support
him and let me tell you why he's going
to have a lot to be proud of and i'm
going to choose my words carefully
because i'm appearing as an official and
this is not a campaign related
appearance but but i'm proud to be part
of this administration that has done
such work to bring america back from the
brink of a recession to create
record job growth uh to build
achievements that would not have been
thought possible just a couple of years
ago like the bipartisan infrastructure
law that that i have the honor of
working on you know people scoffed at
the idea that you could get anything
done on a bipartisan basis
pete is just he's just such an
inauthentic nothing i always describe
him he's just a suit he's just a suit
that they put a generic guy in who would
say all the generic stuff
and then you know you're just going to
be this like little nothing footnote in
history the fact that the
interviewer was saying well you run it's
like they probably want pete to run
because he stands for nothing right so
it's just like you can manipulate him in
any which way possible but he knows joe
biden is not running it's so idiotic to
say that all this stuff about the job
growth yes if you crush
millions and millions of jobs eventually
the jobs will come back when you let
people out of their houses again it's
all lies gay pete has no knowledge of
transportation he was the mayor of south
bend indiana they said oh we need a
transportation secretary let's look at
the oppression olympics people can we
get
a
lesbian with a limp no we don't have a
good one okay can we get a gay guy ah
got one okay and can we find a trans
health secretary got one okay and do we
have a black lesbian to be the press
secretary got one and do we have a furry
to be in charge of nuclear waste oh he's
got one of those too
but he just is nothing right he's sort
of like he wants to be he sort of sounds
like obama he has a little bit
of the obama affect but it's interesting
that gay pete's going all in on this so
it just should be noted kamala harris
when it comes out that something's wrong
with biden she was lying to all of us
gay pete was lying to all of us uh and
it's like why are they supporting him
well politics is a weird game and you
know strange bedfellows and you have to
protect your ass it's like a constant
protection racket with everybody but the
thing is he is breaking down at
extraordinary uh at an extraordinary
rate there was uh well i'm going to show
you some video from friday and we could
have i could have spent the next hour
uh showing you clips of him being unable
to read say things sensibly we're just
gonna pick a couple things here's here
he is struggling with the prompter
it is noteworthy that the percentage of
women who registered to vote and cast a
ballot is consistently higher than the
percentage of the men who do so end of
quote repeat the line
women are not without electoral and or
political or maybe precisely not and or
or political power
end of quote repeat the line look
i fumble words sometimes when i'm doing
this as i often tell you guys i have a
prompter in front of me that doesn't
tell me what to say it just says the
order of the show right so it tells me
like what's coming up next what clip am
i throwing to the rest of this is coming
out of my brain what's more interesting
than him reading end of quote repeat the
line
is that he basically has been reduced
to an elderly man who just reads
pretty poorly off a teleprompter he does
not know what he is saying he often
rampages through these things stumbling
and stammering and doesn't pick up all
of the things that he knocked down right
like he doesn't actually realize that
he's made all of these mistakes he says
all of these random things then he tells
us that he's not allowed to talk and
that he's going to get in trouble and
they don't want him to talk and a whole
bunch of other stuff
here he is on the bike again this
weekend he didn't fall off this time
that's pretty good
some of the groups want i don't look
like a fool in this interview
but i put a helmet on because it was a
tough interview
but all kids aside i think that uh
all right whatever it's not such a big
deal about the helmet it's just that he
just doesn't know what he's doing and
it's like the image of that him standing
there mocking himself for the helmet do
you think any other world leaders are
afraid of this guy do you think they
honestly think he's in charge
like does anyone really believe that any
of this is working can you picture
uh what obama or trump would have done
in that situation like i mean come on
you guys got it but then there's this
other thing where he just doesn't know
what he's doing right and again he's the
pilot of the plane if you think of the
country as a plane right and you want
even if you don't like exactly the
direction that the plane is going right
you want to land there but they want to
go this way you roughly want the plane
to land you don't want the plane to
burst
into flames mid-air you don't want the
plane to go down into the into the ditch
so i would like things to be better here
here's a couple images that we got from
twitter this is from rnc research these
are the notes they zoomed in on the
notes that they often hand joe biden now
i get it people have notes he has to
remember names he has to remember
locations all sorts of stuff that is
just fine however we zoomed into one of
these things let's take a look at this
you enter the roosevelt room and say
hello to participants you take your seat
press enters you give brief comments
press departs you ask liz shuler
president afl-cio a question you
thank participants you depart with you
in capital letters because he is not
sure who he
is this is a problem
this is a big problem uh so what's cnn
saying about all of this well uh
again they're coming around because the
truth is a time release capsule for
mainstream media
even the economy to some extent you've
heard biden say this is putin's fault i
think that excuse is sort of uh wearing
thin with people across the board there
is this sense that he's not quite
getting where he needs to go so what do
you do if you're sitting at home you
have a job but you're kind of strapped
by inflation so what's the takeaway here
what's the long-term you know what it's
so interesting because this time you
know a year ago the president could look
at these numbers and tout them and sort
of boast about them now that's
completely changed because the name of
the game is inflation you've got
ordinary americans paying more in terms
of higher gas prices food prices even
though they save so much during that
pandemic they're now eating into those
savings so buy-in is going to obviously
be blamed for this
so what's super interesting about this
is you guys know that this is all on
biden like you don't have to be a wizard
to remember that in the four years under
the orange man the economy was going
bananas
in a good banana sense it was a good
bunch of bananas okay
things were great black and latino
unemployment was at an all-time low
obviously covid and lockdowns and all of
that mangled that but the basic
structure of the economy the basic idea
of lowering taxes unleashing competition
and businesses uh getting businesses to
return to america all of those things it
was all working it really was all
working you may not have liked
donald trump's skin color and you may
not have liked his hair and some of the
way he spoke in the tweets but that is a
fact then we
elect this human corpse who doesn't
really stand for anything other than
he's been in government for 47 years
obviously never really made anything
happen otherwise things would be better
and there would be no use for him to be
president obviously
his candidacy in many ways was an a
complete exposure of the fact that obama
didn't do a great job when it came to
anything systemic racism the economy
blah blah blah because that ushered in
trump so then why did we bring in biden
to fix it doesn't make any sense uh but
biden now is running out of excuses
because every time he says it's putin's
price hike the average person now is
realizing that hey that's just it's just
not true you're in charge of this
country so if a [ __ ] if a leader of
another country can just jack our gas
prices up cause our inflation to go up
cause us to have supply chain issues and
all of those things if that is true well
then it is your job to make sure that
those things don't happen so nobody's
buying this putin price hike thing
anymore but every now and again remember
he blames putin for everything it's
always putin but every now and again he
accidentally says something else
when it comes to the gas prices
uh we're going through an incredible
transition
that is taking place that god willing
when it's over we'll be stronger and the
world will be stronger and less relying
on fossil fuels
when this is over
do you get the level of mixed messaging
that that is so on one hand the prices
are going up because of putin putin is a
bad dude he went into ukraine it's
causing all gas prices to rise
and he's also always yelling at gas
companies for price gouging even though
they're just responding to the market
okay they want to make a profit they
want to actually put gas in people's
cars and have people come to their gas
station there is some level of
competition that goes on there but he's
always blaming putin for all of this but
then right there he says well actually
it's because we're going through this
transition we've got to get off this
stuff this is an incredible opportunity
and it's like man those things are
completely at odds with each other
completely at odds which is it man is it
that we need gas and but putin's a bad
dude or is it that we're actually doing
it to ourselves because you guys have
your green new deal and you're trying to
destroy the way the known world uh was
able to build itself over the last say
hundred years which one is it uh but of
course the problem with these people is
they lie about everything they are so
deep in the lies they cannot stop lying
all they've got are lies they are in the
bottomless pit of lying and when you are
in that bottomless pit where there is no
bottom
you must lie constantly to not just fall
into the abyss here is black lesbian
karine jean-pierre lying and when we
look at where we are economically and we
are in a strong
we are stronger economically than we
have been uh in history when you look at
the unemployment numbers at 3.6 percent
uh when you look at the jobs numbers uh
more than 8.7 million of new jobs
created
it's just it's such lies and everyone
knows it's live where did those jobs
come from lady is it because there are a
gajillion new companies that are all
thriving right now or is it because you
forced all of these people out of work
well one of my favorite meme makers
online this guy mazemore
he had a funnier version of that and
when we look at where we are
economically and we are in a strong
we are stronger economically than we
have been uh in history
the internet's pretty good when you want
it to be okay so where does this all
lead us
the biden thing is is crumbling it's
crumbling intellectually it's crumbling
politically there's almost no support
for it right even think about it this
way i get if you watch this show you're
probably not the biggest biden supporter
in the first place but you know biden
voters right where are the biden
supporters i mean i get you can get like
sort of half person
you know gay pete you can get him in a
suit he's just nothing in a suit you can
get him he's paid by the administration
to say i support buy it you can get
kamala to say i support him but where
are the regular people who are like i
really like joe biden i sure do think
joe biden's good i'm not talking about
political hacks and i'm not talking
about media people i'm talking about the
regular people
like the base doesn't like him right i
mean nobody likes him so what are they
going to do well if i've learned one
thing over the last seven or eight years
while doing this show
if you take the left and you look at the
sum totality of their ideas they will
always get worse there is no
self-reflection
there is no ability to say hey maybe we
should put our foots on our foot on the
break as we're going off the cliff they
will always find someone worse they will
always find a worse set of ideas
uh and that is a perfect segue to this
tweet by gavin newsom
we're about to celebrate independence
day but freedom is under attack by
republican leaders in states like
florida banning books restricting speech
making it harder to vote criminalizing
women and doctors it's time to stand up
don't let them take your freedom okay so
first off obviously i have to put some
money in the jar and we will give this
money at the end of the year i've
officially announced we will give this
money at the end of the year to get
someone out of california because nobody
should have to live under that freak
okay gavin newsom is you know my
feelings about avenues obviously
he is soulless he is genuinely soulless
i mean that i actually mean that i don't
mean it to be hyperbolic i mean that if
your entire existence is based on lying
the fact that he dare say the word
freedom as if he cares about anyone's
freedom after what he has done in
california destroyed san francisco
as the mayor of san francisco and then
because he's a progressive and because
there is only one type of privilege in
the united states and its democrat
privilege you then fail up through the
system so you get a one-state party like
california which has higher taxes
constantly and there's fires all over
the place and water shortages and
homelessness and drug use and horrible
schools and bad policing and all of the
stuff you get all the stuff but but
newsom's doing something if newsom is
good at one thing he's good at using the
system to his advantage so no matter
what newsome gets exposed for it never
takes him out right he eats he eats with
um
with lobbyists at french laundry the
most expensive restaurant in california
during the lockdowns they rack up thirty
thousand dollars in booze
doesn't matter it's like you just get
away with it right now he's vacationing
in montana which is supposedly an
anti-gay state that he has banned
california from doing any official
business with but he can go there and do
his thing there there's no hypocrisy
that would ever get him to look in the
mirror this is this is his driving force
the hypocrisy the abuse the elitism it
is all part of what is driving him
and he realizes so this is where i'll
give him credit he realizes biden's done
biden is gone and he is a soulless
power-hungry monster who dare uses the
word freedom everything he said in that
can we pull that tweet up again connor
can you pull the tweet up again
everything he said is a lie in there
that they're banning books in florida
not true actually they've been banning
books in california because of words
that are in certain books like uh to
kill a mockingbird restricting speech no
one's restricting anyone's speech here
in florida it's against the first
amendment making it harder to vote
completely not true he wants people to
have ids unlike the ridiculous
california system i'm talking about
desantis obviously criminalizing women
and doctors obviously not obviously not
florida actually has a very
very i would say moderate policy on
abortion that was just passed by
governor ron desantis and their
republican legislature which went into
effect i think it goes into effect this
week maybe it was last week 15 weeks
three and a half months that is as
freaking moderate compromising as you
can get most people in america are there
they're not on board with eight month
abortions like that genuine psychopath i
honestly believe that gavin newsom is an
evil psychopath that is my political
analysis of gavin newsom but why am i
bringing all this up because i think
something good is starting to present
itself
biden is done right hillary trump like
there's an old world that's
sort of on the way out now trump's
probably going to run so he's not fully
part of this but that whole thing about
all of those people is sort of passing
us now and there's a new thing on the
horizon and what that new thing is i
think is represented by florida and
california and i happen to have lived in
both of those states and i have to have
fled one of those states for the other
the fight that america is about to face
is going to be a fight between those two
ideas do you want big government
do you want the ability for bureaucrats
to lock you in their house when they go
out to eat do you want high taxes do you
want ineffectual uh nonsensical policies
that are bringing in vocism and turning
your boys into girls and making racists
out of everyone all those things do you
want that
california gavin newsom or do you want
freedom
do you want low taxes do you want the
government to not be part of every facet
of your life do you do you want any of
those things do you want a flourishing
economy do you want a place put upside
politics for a second
guys you
happier here or in california here you
happier here you happier here okay
it is obvious the the the quality of
life once government is off your back
once the machine is off your back once
you have a little more money in your
wallet i mean think of the income tax
thing alone the fact there is no income
tax
here in florida income tax at the end of
the year you've been taxed you know
payroll tax and sales tax and tax on
this and homeowners tax and all these
taxes right and then at the end of the
year the government comes in and says
hey we just want more of your money now
california has one of the highest if not
highest income taxes right so you're
paying probably 11 or so and here
there's none right so you get more of
your money at the end and you can do
some stuff with your house or you could
buy a boat or you could save that money
or you could buy bitcoin or any of those
things but the but putting that all
aside
is california run better because of it
has more money i mean this is where
democrats catch everybody they think oh
if the government just takes more money
we have more money to do stuff that
things will be done better and it's
simply not true we have roads here in
florida the roads are actually way
better way better i've been driving all
over this state i love this freaking
state and i've been driving all over the
place we don't have potholes everywhere
we don't have just garbage all lit
littered all over the street we don't
have homeless encampments everywhere so
how is it that florida figured out a way
to say we don't want more of your money
at the end of the year and we're still
going to have all the stuff that
california has there is nothing good
that california has that florida does
not have anyway gavin newsom is doing
something wise because he's nothing
other than a polit a soulless soulless
that's the word i want to attach to this
man he is a soulless political hack
and but he's doing something wise
because he knows biden's on the way out
and he's pushing himself as the 2024 guy
and i say let's have that fight let's
have that fight between california and
florida because that really is where
america is at and ron desantis is not
just going to sit there and take it like
most republicans would he put out
this ad going after newsom when families
are uprooting from the pacific coast to
go almost 3 000 miles in search of a
better life that's telling you something
yes we've created a citadel of freedom
here that has attracted people and we're
proud of it but let's just be clear
california is driving people away with
their terrible governance
some of the best weather in the world in
southern california they have some of
the best natural advantages probably the
best natural advantages of any state in
this country and for the entire history
of california they never lost population
until this recent governor got into
office and now they're hemorrhaging
population
it's almost hard
to drive people out of a place like
california given all their natural
advantages and yet they're finding a way
to do it
truth
truth and ain't it refreshing when you
hear it it is not easy for people to
uproot i had to move two companies here
bring my employees with me make sure
everybody wanted to come here everyone
had to find houses and get cars and and
change all of these things in their
lives right uh two of the guys in here
are from cali it's not like you just
want to pick up oh okay i'm gonna leave
my family and go right it's like but
thousands thousands and thousands of
people have done it
nobody is moving to california how
stupid or brain-dead would you have to
yes i'm gonna leave florida and free
florida and i'm gonna move to california
and pay more in taxes and live in filth
and have homeless encampments everywhere
and drug use and all that stuff nobody's
going that way gavin newsom is the
number one u-haul salesman for people
that want to move east because they're
all going that way and when i moved here
we have we had these two big moving
trucks to get all of our stuff over here
and it took forever to get all of our
stuff here because the moving truck
people told us the problem is that in in
normal times
there's an ebb and flow across the
country right in normal times sometimes
people are moving from sometimes people
do actually leave florida you might go
from florida to north carolina or you
might even go further west you might go
from california arizona whatever people
are just migrating all over the place
what gavin newsom has caused is
thousands and thousands hundreds of
thousands of people as rhonda sansa's
reference there california for the first
time ever in the last two years lost
population the first time ever and it's
100 because of him
uh they cannot get trucks because a
truck is supposed to you move somebody
from california and then the truck guy
he's got to make some money so now he's
got a truck an empty truck say in
florida well he needs that truck to get
back to california because that's where
the truck is supposed to be he would
want to take some stuff in that truck
have someone pay him to move a couch but
there's nobody going back that way so
gavin newsom has destroyed lives he has
uprooted a lot of people but i will say
this thank you gavin newsom because my
businesses are thriving my guys are
happy i'm happy we're happy and living a
much better life so that's the fight
that america has to have that's the
fight that's coming i guarantee you mark
mark it down someone have a pen and
paper you have a pen and paper mark it
down reuben called it today that's the
fight that's the fight america needs to
have that's the fight we deserve to have
do you want to live free or do you want
to leave california style that is the
fight that we have to have and speaking
of all of that it's me monday over at
the reuben report community here is the
meme that i put up this morning that's
gavin newsom number one u-haul salesman
join us in california for homelessness
crime random people with guns high gas
prices and much more saw dozens and
dozens of you putting up other memes on
there and let's just jump to a couple
comments and then we got a cold clothes
for you in just a moment genie says it
seemed like elon was just playing
chicken with twitter love it he didn't
blink and he exposed their bot farm
maybe that's what it was all about
you know you just have to think imagine
the level of intelligence this guy has i
mean it not only sort of up here but the
level of intelligence meaning the people
he is around in all of these companies
knowing what's really going on okay
he had to have known that it was going
to be far worse than the five percent
and those of you that are on twitter uh
you know that something feels way more
manipulated now than it did even even
two months ago so something really
really weird so
maybe he was playing chicken the entire
time maybe he was playing chicken with
the tweeter
margo says dave you're supposed to warn
us when you bring on the cackling one
yeah i didn't warn everybody connor that
one's on you we should have warned you
if we bring on the cackling woman or
crazy eyes aoc or i know it's like a
whole it's a lot of warnings the whole
show would just be warnings you know
that stuff amy says if newsom is the
democrat nominee for potus then we must
have desantis as the republican it would
be an epic battle of a tale of two
states and florida wins hands down yeah
that's that's really what i'm feeling it
really was locking in my brain over the
weekend
do we need another fight another trump
biden fight is that really what it feels
like america needs right now
do we need another trump hillary fight
does that feel like what america needs
or to get past all of this stuff
do we really need
a fight of they happen to be younger but
you know let's say prime of their alive
people who have run
two states on opposite coasts who have
done everything 180
180 degrees differently than each other
and then it would show a fight it would
show a true battle of ideas not who
grabbed her by the [ __ ] and who killed
this one or raped this one or married to
the rapist or blah blah blah all that
stuff it's like let's have it out let's
get this thing to its volition and then
let's move on and if half the country
uh wants gavin newsom in california then
may god help us all but that's the fun
the the fight that we have to have they
are is that right
phoenix is giving me some info on the
fly there oh two of the most i thought
it said two of i thought the two most
populated states in the country they're
two of the most populated i know that i
didn't know i thought for a second you
were saying florida was number two that
can't be um
but yes california is a massive
juggernaut it has been run into the
ground and uh and any of you watching
from california and i know we've got a
lot of viewers particularly in oc that
does seem to be a bastion of sanity uh
in uh in california you're welcome here
in florida oh and i'm getting an update
on the fly california number one in
population new york number two florida
number three i did not know that
i did not know that weird wild stuff
guys if you want to join me in miami on
thursday night with lisa booth and with
dave reboy and christina pusha
daverubin.com events i think there's a
couple vip tickets left not totally sure
on that my full interview with bill
o'reilly is up right now and i leave you
on this
monday with a cold close see you
tomorrow
i know you guys are always excited to
hear what i got to say i don't have i i
don't have anything to preview for you
at this time i don't have anything to
share right now so i'm not going to get
ahead of the president on that i don't
have anything to share on that either
but i don't have any updates on that as
soon as we as soon we have something we
will we will share that can't speak to
anything more besides you know we would
refer you to the irs on that specific
thing look again i don't have anything
to preview or announce at this time i
just don't have anything to read out i
can't speak to that from here i'm not
going to get ahead of the president i
actually don't have anything for you i'm
not going to get ahead of the
president's decision i'm i just is not
i'm not going to speak to it i don't
have anything for you at this time to
preview i don't have anything for you to
pray for you again i don't have anything
to share with you i don't have anything
else to read out and i just don't have
anything to share at this time i just i
don't have anything to share i'm not
going to give i'm not going to negotiate
from here not going to give a deadline
from here i don't have an executive
order uh executive action to speak to so
i don't have any uh we don't have any
calls to read out i don't have more to
share i don't have anything for you to
prove for you i just don't have anything
for you to share at this time i don't
have a a call to preview for you i we
just don't have more to share i don't
have any calls to preview at this time i
there's i just don't have anything to
share i mean that's a hypothetical that
i can't really speak to i cannot speak
to that particular uh vacancy i'm i'm
not going to i'm not going to go on to
limit tests so um i don't have anything
to share all i can tell you is that we
don't normally speak on uh vacancies i
cannot speak uh to any uh discussions
that are happening i i don't have
anything to preview for you at this time
i just cannot speak to that from here i
i just don't have anything to to say i'm
not going to get ahead of what those
actions are going to be
we just don't have anything to share i
just don't have a call to preview at
this time but i don't have anything
to share so i don't have anything
specifically on the va yeah so
we don't have anything clearly right now
at this time
foreign